do you see some of the techniques that
you talk about as manipulative
manipulation is whether or not I'm
trying to exploit you hurt you
um
am I trying to manipulate a bank robber
and to let me save his life
yeah
so manipulation is like what am I what
am I trying to do to you yeah
so but you don't see the negative
connotation if you're trying to uh bring
a better future it's not manipulation
stop if I'm trying to bring a better
future if I'm being genuine and honest
like
I compliment you yeah if if my
compliment is genuine
that's not manipulation
like and better but you know if I think
you know you're you got a pair of shoes
that that are the dumbest looking things
I've ever seen and I go wow those are
great shoes nah that's manipulation
so there's uh there's guys I call Warren
Buffett who are big on integrity and
honesty what's the role of uh
lying in an effective language bad idea
lying is just a bad idea for a variety
of reasons
first of all
um there's really good change the other
side it's a better lie than you are
they're going to spot it right off the
bat yeah
secondly
they could be luring you into a trap to
see if you will lie
thirdly the chances are they're going to
find out that you lied to them
eventually
is really high
and then the penalties and the taxes
are going to be way higher than what you
had in the first place so long term you
want to have a reputation of somebody
with integrity and the more you lie the
harder it is to maintain that reputation
exactly and word's going to get out